veamos el mecanismo para una reacción sn
dos del lado izquierdo tenemos una luro
de alquilo o también llamado halogenuro
de alquilo y sabemos que el bromo es un
poco más electro negativo que este
carbono entonces el bromo retira un poco
de densidad electrónica del carbono por
lo que este carbono es un poco positivo
podemos decir que es parcialmente
positivo ese es nuestro centro electro
físico entonces del lado izquierdo
tenemos al electro filo y del lado
derecho sabemos que este es el ión
hidróxido que lo podemos obtener de el
hidróxido de sodio y tenemos una carga
formal negativa en el oxígeno lo que lo
hace un buen núcleo filo entonces este
es nuestro núcleo filo
y del lado izquierdo tenemos a nuestro
electro filo al que en este vídeo
también me referiré como sustrato
entonces este alumno de alquilo es
nuestro sustrato y por un vídeo anterior
sabemos que el núcleo filo atacará al
electro filo porque las cargas opuestas
se atraen
esta carga negativa es atraída a esta
carga parcial positiva entonces un par
de electrones libres en el oxígeno
atacan al carbón o parcialmente positivo
y al mismo tiempo los electrones de este
enlace se van con el bromo dibujar el
bromo por aquí el bromo ya tenía tres
pares de electrones libres pero ahora
tiene otro par de electrones libres los
pondré de color rosa entonces este
enlace se rompe y el par de electrones
se va junto con el bromo lo que le da
una carga formal negativa este es el año
en bromuro y también formamos un enlace
entre
el oxígeno y este carbono y este enlace
se forma con este par de electrones
libres que resalte de color azul
entonces esos dos electrones de color
azul forman este enlace y así obtenemos
nuestro producto que es un alcohol
entonces el mecanismo sn 2 es un
mecanismo concertado porque el núcleo
filo ataca al electro filo al mismo
tiempo que se va el grupo saliente así
que en este mecanismo sólo hay un paso y
ahora supongamos que hicimos una serie
de experimentos para determinar la ley
de velocidad de esta reacción porque
recuerden que la ley de velocidad se
determina experimentalmente entonces r
mayúscula es la velocidad de reacción y
es igual a la constante de velocidad k
por la concentración de la luro de al
kilo
que experimentalmente se determinó que
está elevada a la primera potencia por
la concentración de lyon hidróxido
también elevada a la primera potencia ok
y esto qué significa bueno significa que
si incrementamos la concentración de
nuestro alumno de alquilo si aumentamos
la concentración del alumno de alquilo
por un factor de 2 qué ocurre con la
velocidad de reacción
bueno la velocidad de la reacción es
proporcional a la concentración del
alumno de alquilo a la primera potencia
entonces 2 a la 1 es igual a 2 y eso
significa que la velocidad de reacción
total aumentará en un factor de 2 así
que al duplicar la concentración de
nuestro alumno de alquilo mientras
mantenemos la concentración de lyon
hidróxido constante se duplica la
velocidad de la reacción o también si
mantenemos la misma concentración del
alumno de alquilo y duplicamos la
concentración del hidróxido
aumenta la velocidad de la reacción por
un factor de 2 el doble y esta ley
determinada experimentalmente tiene
sentido con nuestro mecanismo entonces
si incrementamos la concentración del
núcleo filo o la del electro filo
incrementamos la frecuencia de
colisiones entre los dos lo que aumenta
la velocidad total de la reacción así
que el hecho de que nuestra ley de
velocidad sea proporcional a la
concentración del sustrato y del núcleo
filo se ajusta a la idea de un mecanismo
de un solo paso y finalmente veamos por
qué le decimos sn dos decimos que es un
mecanismo sn 2 y una reacción sn 2
porque ese es por sustitución
sustitución nuestro núcleo filo
sustituye al grupo saliente aquí lo
podemos ver en el producto final el
núcleo filo sustituyó al grupo saliente
entonces n es por núcleo físico porque
claro la sustitución ocurre gracias a la
sustitución que realiza el núcleo filo y
finalmente el 2 se refiere a be
molecular eso quiere decir que la
velocidad de reacción depende de la
concentración de dos cosas la del
sustrato y la del núcleo filo y eso es
lo diferente de un mecanismo sn uno en
el que la velocidad sólo depende de la
concentración de una sola cosa ahora la
velocidad de reacción también depende de
la estructura del allure o de al kilo es
decir de la estructura del sustrato del
lado izquierdo tenemos una luro de
alquilo metilo seguido por una luro de
alquilo primario el carbono unido a
nuestro bromo está unido directamente a
un grupo alquilo después tenemos una
luro de
y lo secundario el carbono unido al
bromo está unido a dos grupos al kilo y
después tenemos una luro de alquilo
terciario este carbono está unido a tres
grupos al kilo y resulta que el alero de
metilo y el alero de al kilo primario
son los que reaccionan más rápido en un
mecanismo sn 2 mientras que los saludos
de alc y los secundarios reaccionan muy
lento y los saludos de alquilo
terciarios reaccionan tan lento que
prácticamente podemos decir que no
reaccionan por medio de un mecanismo sn
2 y esto tiene sentido cuando pensamos
en el mecanismo porque recuerden que el
núcleo filo tiene que atacar al electro
filo el núcleo filo tiene que estar lo
suficientemente cerca del carbono
electro físico para poder formar un
enlace y el impedimento estético evita
que eso pase entonces un alumno de
alquilo terciario tiene estos grupos
metilo muy voluminosos
aunque el núcleo filo pueda atacar
veamos un vídeo para entender mejor todo
esto
este es nuestro alumno de metilo en el
que el carbono está directamente unido
al halógeno que lo he puesto de color
amarillo y este es el núcleo filo que
puede ser el ión hidróxido el núcleo
filo se acerca al electro filo por el
lado opuesto al grupo saliente y podemos
ver que no hay impedimento estético en
el allure o de metilo después tenemos
una luro de alquilo primario el carbono
unido al hidrógeno solo tiene un grupo
al kilo y aún es fácil que el núcleo
filo pueda acercarse pero si pasamos a
un alumno de alquilo secundario en un
alumno de alquilo secundario podemos ver
que el carbono unido al halógeno también
está unido a dos grupos metilo y ahora
es un poco difícil para el núcleo filo
poder acercarse con la orientación
adecuada así que estos grupos metilo
voluminosos hacen más difícil que el
núcleo filo
a acercarse lo suficiente al carbono
electro físico y en el caso del alumno
de alquilo terciario tenemos tres grupos
alquilo uno dos y tres
hay más impedimento estético por lo que
es todavía más difícil que el núcleo
filo se acerque como vimos en el vídeo
para una reacción sn dos necesitamos
disminuir el impedimento estético
entonces si analizamos este alumno de
alquilo el carbono que está unido
directamente a nuestro halógeno
únicamente está unido a un grupo al kilo
así que este es un alumno de alquilo
primario y eso hace que ésta sea una
buena reacción sn 2 porque al disminuir
el impedimento estético permitimos que
el núcleo filo pueda atacar al electro
filo